let's call it the plumbing of the
financial system how cash and risk flow
through the financial system it came
very close to breaking badly during the
financial crisis and right now the main
concern is whether it will break under
pressure again thanks very much depend
on their creditors continuing to provide
credit on a daily basis now of course
regulators have been looking into that
problem and have been pushing banks to
hold much more capital and more
liquidity so that they can survive
short-term interruptions and creditor
financing but there are still some
fragilities in that system I would start
with what's known as the tri-party repo
system
there are three types of players
involved on the one hand there's
accreditors a typical creditor would be
a large money market fund then there's
the borrower's typical borrower would be
a large securities dealer typically
these days of Bank such as Lehman was at
the time and then in the middle is a
clearing bank special-purpose financial
institution whose job it is
operationally to handle these overnight
loans from the lenders to the borrower's
and normally that works very well on a
daily basis each of the major dealers
borrows in excess of 100 billion dollars
a day in that market without problems
every day there's a new loan that's
taken out late in the afternoon our new
series of loans by each bank to finance
its inventory of securities and that
mature is the next midday and then
there's a interim period of two or three
hours depending on how well they
re-engineer the system during which
declaring bank provides credit to the to
the Securities Dealers and it's that
transition during that that mid day
period that's operationally tricky and
is a system fragility if a bank were to
run into trouble during that period well
you know creditors are not going to
offer it loans for the next day that
would leave the clearing bank holding
the bag exposed to the credit of the of
the securities dealer the borrowing bank
normally that would be fine because the
clearing bank has collateral the same
securities that are used to finance the
loans overnight are used during this
interim period as well but you know
there's a tail risk there and you
wouldn't want to take any risks that the
clearing bank could get into
difficulties or find its balance sheet
imbalanced by that by that huge amount
of new securities that it has to finance
on its own
in the long run I think it would be
prudent to take these large tri-party
repo clearing organizations out of an
already very complex large financial
institution and put them in a standalone
utility it could be more easily
supervised and it doesn't the fact that
it exists inside a large bank is a
reason to save that bank from failure
that causes moral hazard if the
tri-party clearing organization were
outside of the bank and the bank were to
take unnecessary or unlucky Gamble's and
run into difficulties the government
would not feel pressed to save it merely
because it was running one of these
tri-party repo clearing organizations it
could let it stand or fall on its own
merits right now that's not the case
you